hello world has a gun
my name is David silver I am the
curriculum lead for the Udacity
self-driving car nanodegree program
welcome and I'm Anthony Navarro I am the
product lead for the self-driving car
nanodegree program and we're excited to
be here today talking to you about
everything self-driving cars we are lots
of questions coming up and we hope there
are lots more questions that you all ask
anything you want to ask about
self-driving cars the nanodegree program
we are excited to answer first we'll
we'll start with a little public safety
announcement so Anthony and I are both
drinking I've got Jack Daniels and he's
got a Carrera sorry
not a better beer right now we should
say that neither of you sponsors of the
hundred degree program we just went
across the street and bought them one of
the great things about self-driving cars
is that there are a lot of accidents in
the world an estimated million deaths a
year there's a lot due to self driving
cars 35,000 in the u.s. even drinking
and driving a self-driving cars not not
self for every human driven car
accidents motion of those accidents are
are caused by humans and many of them
are caused by alcohol and so a future in
which we can drink and not have
accidents I think is is a great future
and you
should not drink and drive don't do it
really bad really bad but when you're
not driving enjoy a few drinks welcome
to our drink and feel free we've got the
chat channel open we're monitoring it
and so we'll be there to answer any of
your questions hopefully there's some
good questions to come through otherwise
you get to listen to David and I talk
about anything that we want to talk
about which may or may not be of
interest to you so let's see we've got a
pretty good world audience it sounds
like coming around here so hopefully we
chose a great time
so first is there any questions about
the self-driving car curriculum
hopefully a lot of you are going to be
signing up soon have been accepted or
maybe you're just really interested in
what stuff jogging cars are in general
or how you get jobs in those cool so we
have a bunch of people saying hi from
Palo Alto I saw a few people from
Ontario one person from Malaysia
maybe then there's whele Michigan and
somebody would see somebody asked what
do you specialize in so I worked on the
autonomous vehicle team at Ford Motor
Company before I continued acity and at
Ford I worked on the computational
hardware platform team we actually
called it the domain controller team at
Ford and so we were testing out a lot of
the different computer platforms
available to see if they were fast
enough for our needs and benchmarking
them what did you do before you came to
us so I was actually over with Lockheed
Martin and I did some work on their
satellite systems that they were doing
and then also on autonomous systems
research and development and so one of
the programs I worked on was autonomous
vehicles for the military and kind of
doing a lot of different testing and
things with that so it was a lot of fun
time the systems are kind of great so
looks like we've got some questions
pouring in - is there any information
available right now that describes the
course content for each term for example
topics covered syllabus I think sure you
think David's done a lot with that I
have I have for better for worse the the
syllabi for the three terms live on my
blog you can find them if if you go to
the Udacity homepage for the nanodegree
program which you link out to my blog or
if you just search for Udacity
self-driving car syllabus
in google they'll pop up and and we can
actually even get one of our colleagues
to post the links in the chat channel
there's a different syllabus for each
term term 1 2 & 3 and we're actually
finally going to pull those on to the
actual nanodegree homepage so they're
not just living on my blog yeah so
there's another question about do you
have to attend the lectures live or can
you watch them later so our lectures are
actually all recorded so you can do em
at your own pace your own time you don't
have to do them around our schedule and
there none of them are actually live
every now and then we do some live
walkthroughs or live events like this
but everything is always recorded so you
can always access offline yeah and
actually as far as the syllabus goes and
in addition to simply directing people
where to search online or where to go to
online I'll just run through the
syllabus really quickly so the program
is nine months long it's divided into
three terms of three months each and
each month covers a different topic in
the autonomous vehicle technology stack
so that by the time you've done the
entire nine month program you've gone
through the entire self-driving car
technology stack so we start with an
introductory month that's month one
month two we cover deep learning which
is an exciting new field in artificial
intelligence generally and very
applicable to self-driving cars deep
learning is is all about using deep
neural networks which is a type of
machine learning tool to learn from data
month three is computer vision this is
more of a traditional way or a classical
way of using images to see the road so
things like look for yellow if you want
to find a lane line a lot of computer
vision is is now being superseded by
deep learning but it's helpful to kind
of know both the the standard approach
and the new deep learning approach so
that's term one introduction deep
learning computer vision term two is
sensor fusion localization and control
so sensor fusion is how you use radar
and lidar and fuse that data together
using mathematical tools called calman
filters in order to understand what to
be what the world around you looks like
so say you you see a vehicle out here
your radar tells you there's another
vehicle out here and your lidar your
laser tells you there's another vehicle
out here how do
figure out if that's one vehicle or two
vehicles and then track that vehicle or
vehicles over time so that's sensor
fusion a month five is localization
which is how we figure out where we are
in the world with GPS nowadays that can
seem really really easy but in fact GPS
is only accurate to within one to two
meters and if you think about like how
big one to two meters is if a car is off
by one to two meters it could be off on
the sidewalk I mean that would be really
really bad so we have more sophisticated
mathematical techniques like particle
filters that help us localize the
vehicle to within single digit
centimeter level accuracy on a map so
that's local ization then month six is
control control is how we actually turn
the steering wheel and hit the throttle
and the brake to follow a trajectory I
mean there are lots of different
algorithms called controllers that can
do that it seems pretty simple like for
you and me it's like you execute a left
turn if you turn too hard you kind of
ease up but but for a computer you
actually need some pretty sophisticated
algorithms to do that and then the final
term on seven eight and nine are path
planning an elective month and finally
system integration path planning is how
we decide where to take the vehicle both
at the macro level like how do we get
between San Jose and San Francisco say
and at the micro level what happens if
like a cat runs out in the road what do
we do and so we build things like cost
functions and try and predict the world
out into the future and then decide what
maneuver we want to take and what
trajectory we want to build and that's
the trajector we ultimately hand off to
the controller to to execute using the
steering wheel and an throttle and brake
so that's path planning month eight is
an elective month where you can go deep
on one of several different topics we
currently have electives in advanced
deboarding which is all about how you
use deep neural networks to identify
pixel by pixel what's going on in an
image you know is this pixel the road is
this pixel this guy is this pixel a car
where's the free space in the image so
that's one option the other elective is
functional safety which is how we verify
that the code we're writing is safe and
reliable and then the final module of
the program the final month is system
integration where we take all of this
stuff you've learned and you work in
teams to put it on
the actual Udacity self-driving car
which we have here in Palo Alto on a
test track and that's one of the really
really exciting things about the course
is at the end you actually get to put
your own code on the the actual Udacity
self-driving cards it's something you
don't have a lot of other opportunities
to do and so we think it's really
exciting awesome
I saw a few more questions come in do we
have a job guarantee with this program
we do not but we actually partner with a
lot of hiring partners who were very
interested in our students and we have a
careers team here to help you prepare
for those interviews so although it's no
guarantee if you do the work on your end
we do the work to help you get to that
next step and get you those interviews
and we do have other challenges like the
boss challenge you're just just about to
close I think that we're you know if you
finish in the top 25 on that one you are
getting an interview with Bosch so there
are exciting things like that
programming language that we use in the
self-driving car course we use Python
initially and then we get into C++ C++
is very important for self-driving
vehicles especially they're basically
embedded systems and you need a lot to
happen really fast on the chip so C++
enables that kind of communication
tell us about vision based cars or I
guess comparing vision based versus
using lidar z' i would say it's not like
using one or the other it's you know
they're better at different things and
so you know light our letter is great
for seeing you know 3d the depth image
but it's not very good for like high
density and where you have camera it's
very good high density but it's a 2d
image so you have to kind of combine
those and that's what David was talking
about the sensor fusion becomes very
important and how you combine all these
pieces together what is the hardest part
of autonomous driving algorithm design
probably that nobody knows the answer
yet there's a lot it's an unknown world
I would say yeah yeah I mean it's a fun
field because so much of it is getting
built out as we go I mean I think two
really large pieces and they do kind of
encompass a large chunk of autonomous
vehicles are the perception stack which
is how do we perceive what's going
around it around us in the world using
cameras radar lidar because there's just
so much sensor data that can come in and
has to all be processed on the vehicle
because the latency up to the cloud and
back is is too slow and so figuring out
how you use the delimited computational
hardware you have on the vehicle in
order to process all this sensor data
fast enough to perceive the world around
you is a really really tough challenge
the other another really hard part of
autonomous vehicle technology is path
planning we have pretty much solved or
at least Google Maps is pretty much
solve for us how the part about how do
we get from one city to another but it
remains really really difficult to
figure out you know if you come upon a
construction work site and somebody's
waving you around or holding like
temporary stop stop yield signs that
flip back and forth what do you do or
Chris Urmson formerly of the Google
self-driving car project has a funny
story about the Google self-driving cars
encountering a woman in a wheelchair
hurting ducks in the middle of the
street in the car trying to figure out
how to deal with that there's just all
sorts of crazy stories and videos that
you see from self-driving cars people
driving down the wrong side of an
interstate and just path planning around
all of those things is really really
challenging what is the job market for
self-driving cars currently lots I think
every company that I know that's doing
them is hiring auto companies and a lot
of companies are doing it so if you're
looking for a job and you have the
skills and we're here to teach you the
skills there are jobs out there there's
not a shortage of jobs at all is it what
this specific oh I always say I can even
talk a little bit about the automotive
industry and how that plays into the job
market so kind of the traditional
automotive industry you have what are
sometimes called the OEMs original
equipment manufacturers are just auto
manufacturers so those are companies
whose brands you probably recognize like
Ford or mercedes-benz BMW BMW and
mercedes-benz and Fiat Chrysler are
great partners of ours and the
self-driving car program they're looking
to hire folks out of the program and
then there are what are called Tier one
suppliers and these are companies who
you may or may not have heard of who
supply really just the auto makers their
whole business is to supply components
for automakers so those
companies like Bosch Delphi continental
all of whom are great partners of the
self-driving car program and they are
hiring like crazy too because they are
supplying self-driving car components
and systems to the auto manufacturers
and then beyond that you have what are
called tier two suppliers and those are
companies that may supply a lot of
different industries but one of the
industries they supply our cars and so
to your two suppliers will often supply
components to Tier one suppliers who
will ultimately supply a whole system to
an automotive manufacturer kind of
follow that whole chain to your to
supplier might be sensor manufacturer
like valid EIN manufacturers wide ours
or it could be chip manufacturer like
Nvidia who is one of our partners in
producing the entire nanodegree produces
graphics chips that are incredibly
important for self-driving cars because
they allow parallelization of the
computational hardware so you have that
kind of whole stack and everyone in that
stack is hiring and then you have this
kind of whole new stack of companies
like uber and whammo which is part of
Google and DD and Baidu in China even
companies like Yandex and Russia kind of
Internet companies that are beginning to
look at self-driving cars
Apple has now finally come out and
talked a little bit about their self
driving car effort and so you have kind
of the traditional automotive team plus
all of these tech companies and they're
all hiring like crazy to build up their
self-driving car teams yeah so take our
programming get a job in some of the
cars it's awesome do we have any
specific requirements for the type of
computer you will be using yes and no
with a good internet browser and a good
connection you can do everything in our
videos however some of the projects the
biggest thing that they're going to need
is really when we get to the deep
learning side is the GPUs now we do give
AWS credits out but it's a lot easier if
you have like your local machine that
can do that Ubuntu access is I like
using Ubuntu you can use VMs and things
like that but at least a good a decent
computer definitely helps get you
through these projects
can you explain some of the projects you
make during the nanodegrees if you want
to run through a couple of them but I
think I think you did a pretty good job
with the syllabus to me talking I'll
just pick out a few so one of the most
popular projects in is within the deep
learning module that's fairly early on
in the program and it's called
behavioral cloning and the idea with
this project is that you build it a deep
neural network and train a deep neural
network to clone human driving behavior
and the the human in question who's
actually you this is done in a simulator
it's a little bit like a video game and
you'll download the Udacity simulator
onto your own computer and there's a car
on a track and you drive the simulated
car around the simulated track just like
in a video game and all of that data
gets recorded to your computer and then
you use that data to train a deep neural
network and once you've trained the
network you can actually switch the
simulator into autonomous mode and your
network will drive the car and so you
get to see your deep neural network
driving the car around the track and now
of course it's not that simple it takes
a lot of tries to finally get your
network to a place where the car will
drive around the track and it it can be
even sometimes a little bit of a
frustrating project but the the reward
when you finally get the network to
drive your car around the track
autonomously is really really fun I will
say that as a student that was like one
of my favorite projects and it like
David said it was kind of frustrating
for a while and then when it worked
there was like jumping up and down you
know trying to keep quiet cuz it was
like middle of the night but super happy
that it actually worked so is a huge
sense of accomplishment yeah
another project much further along in
the course at the beginning of term 3 is
our path planning project that's again
in the simulator and in this case it's a
simulated highway 3 lane highway or six
lane highway three lanes on your side of
the road and you have to build a path
planner that plans several seconds out
and figures out you know when you should
change lanes to pass vehicles to get
where you're going faster but with all
sorts of constraints like you can't
exceed a speed limit you also can't
exceed acceleration and jerk limits
jerkies is kind of the the next
derivative after acceleration to make
sure that the ride is comfortable and
that gives you a real appreciation for
how difficult
is to build a path planner on the road
it's a great portfolio project to take
to employers and then the final project
of the nanodegree actually getting to
put your code on the car you learned
about Ross robot operating system which
is the automotive middleware framework
that our car runs on and that runs on a
lot of cars in particular in academia
it's a great skill set to have to be
able to go to employers and say you've
worked with Ross and built Ross nodes to
drive a car and you get to work with the
team to pull together sensor fusion in
the sensor processing pipelines you've
built and neural networks and the path
planning you've done in localization
filters that you've built and actually
get them to run on a real car so those
are a few of the different projects than
the nanodegree yeah great
another question that I've seen come up
a lot is how many hours does it take for
somebody to do this course now we'd like
to say 10 to 15 but really it kind of
depends on your background if you're
really if you understand a lot of this
stuff really well if you've been through
computer vision classes give it
background in this it's gonna take less
time but if you're you know don't have
that background it's gonna take a little
bit more time so it's a good estimate
just kind of do the first project and
see how long it takes you for that and
then start doing the second project
because it is a little bit harder for
the second project and start gauging
that early but estimate between 10 and
20 hours I would say to really get a
good understanding of that yeah we
survey students and I think the average
number and it is an average there's a
big range just like you were saying the
average number of our students report
spending on the program per week is
about 17 okay which is a really big
commitment you know many of our students
have full-time jobs it's a lot to do but
on the other hand students generally
tend to be really really excited when
they complete the program they've
learned a lot they feel like they've
developed a whole suite of skills that
they didn't have just a few months ago
so it is one of those things where what
you put in is what you get out yep does
this course involve a team project it
does as David mentioned the final
project where you get to put your code
on the car is a team project so you know
you work with team members and you know
I think that's very important because an
industry you're always going to be
working on a team so it's good to get
that experience you
see you know you get to collaborate on
this big project and then all together
you get to put your coat on the car and
so it's really exciting well the content
be good enough for people from other
backgrounds to get a job absolutely
that's the whole point is you don't have
to know this stuff already coming into
it you know like David said kind of you
get in which you put it or you get out
of it what you put in so if you know
your backgrounds and web development or
something else and you come into this
course and you you know really work hard
at it and you develop great projects and
you develop this portfolio basically to
go show an employer absolutely we have
our students already getting hired and
the program is not even completed so
it's definitely capable for that to
happen term three syllabus or David
talked about that a little bit there
should be a lot of information on term
three that's out there so if you're not
able to find it able to find it we can
look into that a little bit what is the
difficulty level for this program it's
not a beginner program I mean we
designed the program to help people who
are already software engineers prepared
for jobs in the autonomous vehicle
industry so that's kind of how we
approached it we do have people in the
program who are not software engineers
have you know some background in
software engineering maybe they studied
math or even like computational biology
we have an accountant I know who's doing
quite well in the program who's taken
other Udacity courses kind of as a lead
up so you don't have to be like a rocket
scientist you don't have to be Superman
to complete the course but the course is
designed for people who know how to code
and there are prerequisites and and in
general if we admit someone to the
program we expect them to be able to
succeed based on what we've seen of
their background you know if they're
willing to put in the time a lot of it
really is just about putting in the time
and the effort it's it's really easy on
a Saturday afternoon or a Tuesday night
to say you know I'd rather watch TV then
like code up my behavioral cloning
project or warned about Coleman filters
and so a lot comes down to like how
excited are you about this and how much
you know effort do you want to put into
it yep
what's the hardware in the car
um the hardware in the car um there's a
lot of hardware in Karla our
self-driving car
we have valid I'm wide arse VLP 16s and
HDL 32 lidar so 16 and 32 beam wide ours
we generally don't run them both at the
same time we usually run one or another
that 32 we use more for actually
building a map and then the 16 can
localize to that map we we use Delphi
ESR radar we have point gray cameras we
have a data speed controller that talks
to the can bus inside the car can is
control area network that's the actual
network running in the car and we did
not have to hack that ourselves we
purchased the vehicle from autonomous
stuff autonomous stuff is an Illinois
based company that makes cars that are
drive by wire so they're not
self-driving but autonomous stuff sold
us this vehicle and handed us a
PlayStation controller video game
controller and said look you can drive
drive this real car with a video game
controller and in fact we could we could
just like stand outside the car and
drive it around like a remote-control
car with the video game controller and
they said if you can drive it with a
video game controller you can program a
computer to drive it and so that's what
we did that was our job is to program
the computer to drive it the computer we
run has an Intel i7 I forget how much
how many gigs of RAM it has and in
NVIDIA Titan X GPU and we're looking at
other computational platforms like the
video drive the x2 that it might run in
the vehicle as well great
is there a grading pattern to this
program I'm assuming that means you're
asking how the how the I guess projects
are getting graded so the projects are
graded with the rubric and it's
pass/fail so as long as you hit
everything in the rubric complete the
project you'll pass the project are we
going to do practicals I don't know what
you mean by that question so if you can
clarify it and be happy to answer it do
we have any success stories of the
program we do we have a lot of success
stories actually and I think I have a
lot even just that we know personally
that we and there's many more that we
don't always hear about but I have
people that are working at many of our
partners and then many people that even
aren't partners are hiring
not even graduates yet hiring our
students because they're showing this
you know capability in this yeah I was
actually funnily enough a few weeks ago
at the office of uh I guess I'll leave
the Monday a major automotive
manufacturer here in Silicon Valley and
I was sitting out in a common area
talking with someone about collaboration
between them and about and Udacity and
someone walked behind and just kind of
looked over at me and said do you work
at Udacity and I said yes and he said
you know I thought this self-driving car
course were you in the self-driving car
course I said yes I was in the
self-driving car course and he said that
is he had done the first term of the
self-driving car course and then gotten
hired on to the autonomous vehicle team
at this automotive manufacturer and so
there are just lots of stories like that
we're starting to see with students
giving jobs at automotive suppliers
manufacturers tech companies other types
of companies working on this stuff
defense contractors and all right
how many dents are on the self-driving
car there are no dents there are a
couple of holes in the bumper when we
bought the vehicle from autonomous stuff
they had two vo p16 lied ours two little
pups basically kind of on each side of
the front bumper and we discovered as we
were working with the vehicle that that
having the the pucks in the front bumper
wasn't ideal because you didn't get a
360 degree wraparound view of the world
you just kind of saw like maybe 180
degrees in front of you and so we
removed the pucks from the front bumper
and put them up on top of the vehicle so
now there are some holes in the front
bumper I'm gonna try to push through a
lot of these we're checking up on
questions oh my god we'll be quick is
there a slack or other collaboration
form yes
which one's the public so there's a
public slack community at Indy zero and
three dot slash comm that you can join
right now there is a student slack
community that you have to enroll to
join at car Indicom and then we also
have forums at discussions udacity.com
where you can if they're more like Stack
Overflow like for asking questions is
there any specific requirements for set
up in my car you'd actually use these
Lincoln we do because we purchased it
from autonomous stuff and you can
definitely go purchase
from autonomous stuff it gets a little
bit more fuzzy if you're gonna try to
turn your own car into that into an
autonomous vehicle and there's a whole
lot that goes into doing that and we
don't cover all that kind of stuff in
the course because there's a lot of
electrical safety many many issues
around that
yeah the purpose of the course really is
to prepare students for getting jobs in
the autonomous vehicle industry and not
so much to actually build your own
self-driving car that is a major and
very expensive effort what we're focused
on is helping students get jobs how
proficient should I be in the Python
write in Python at the start of the
program I would say you should be able
to solve problems with Python not just
like understand the syntax of Python but
actually solve problems with it if given
an abstract problem going to Python and
solve that problem if you can do that
then you're probably at a good spot
requirements for assignments computer
the GPU so I used my laptop that had a
GPU in it it was kind of slow but it
wasn't awful if you yeah if you can get
a 1080 or something higher that's or
that's great but a laptop and a gaming
GPU or at least I had a little bit of a
gaming laptop that would be fine oh yeah
I mean you don't even have to have a GPU
as Anthony mentioned it is helpful but
we provide um credits for launching
Amazon Web Services virtual servers that
have attached GPUs um so if you don't
have your own GPU you can use that this
person's asking about they're a little
concerned about the pace we tweaked due
to family and work commitments are the
weekly deadlines homework projects and
is there some flexibility so every
project has a deadline however those are
flexible deadlines so if you don't hit
it by the deadline that's okay you can
still submit it later what is the kind
of like the hard deadline is the end of
the term so you still where you may you
might have weeks that you can do more
and weeks that you can do less but by
the end of the term all of the work has
to be done and turned in and graded in
order for you to pass the term and move
on to the next term somebody likes Jack
Daniels and hello from Virginia I'm from
Virginia from Reston Virginia Reston
Indiana
both towns is is the market for
self-driving car engineers already full
absolutely not as we were talking
earlier there's companies looking left
and right and every night every day
there's more I think Samsung announced
something today
hiring mm-hmm a bunch of engineers and
they're one of our hiring partners so
any comment that big tech companies such
as Google or Apple showing a little step
back of self-driving car um Apple I mean
there there have been some stories in
the news recently about kind of the
journey of Apple and they've had kind of
an interesting journey because they've
been so secretive
Google seems to be just kind of forging
ahead they they're launching their
chrysler pacifica minivans self-driving
minivans there are a ton of them now and
not me just driving all over the place
and supposedly they're picking up real
passengers in Arizona so it seems like
they are forging ahead full speed yeah
how do you do a direct sunlight on the
camera that's where we get this inter
fusion and you learn how to rely on
other sensors besides the one that may
not be very reliable at the time how to
learn C++ from scratch in this course so
we do have a module that kind of goes
over C++ basics so it's a C++ for
programmers kind of idea so you already
know how to program python you've
already finished a term in Python at
this point and then you can get into C++
and do a little bit from there
there also is a free Udacity C++ course
in the Udacity course catalog that
basically we built for the self-driving
car nanodegree but you can just go now
in search for C++ in the Udacity catalog
enjoying that course if you want to get
a head start do most of the hiring
Partners and opportunities us-based oudy
have partners and other locales we do
have other partners in other locales
however just because if I guess the
nature of it and the companies that are
doing this kind of research it's a lot
happening in the US but there are
companies other places that yeah we have
a number of companies in Germany
so of course mercedes-benz BMW
Volkswagen Audi also suppliers like
Elektra bit continental based out of
Germany we have companies in India a
number of automotive supply type
companies like HCl in India and a lot of
these big multinationals like BMW
mercedes-benz have offices all over the
world China we just had an event here
today actually with Dede on the Chinese
ride-sharing company Japan has a lot of
self-driving car companies that we we
don't have formal partnerships with all
of them but we
we're close to many of them so there's a
lot of work going on all over the place
Canada has a number of offices now uber
and GM both have big self-driving car
offices in Canada ok can we reuse the
code we write in this course any IP
restrictions absolutely we own
everything I'm kidding you we definitely
want you to put it out there it's all
open source you know whatever you do
with the code you write is for your
business you know we're here to promote
the education in this area we don't take
any IP and anything you do with our
courses I think there's something on our
Terms of Service that like maybe we can
use your code to like demonstrate like
show people like samples of what
students have written we have to go back
and double-check our Terms of Service
but but you um you do retain right to
your IP how are we doing going to do
practicals with Lyde ours or other
physical practicals ok so this is kind
of the final project I think you're
referring to so when we have actually
hardware in the loop we can talk a
little bit about this but basically
you're gonna send us your code you're
gonna work with your team you'll send us
the code then we will deploy your code
on the car and run it and see if it
passes you know the project yeah so
that's kind of how the final project
works we have a simulator that ties into
Ross that simulates lidar and radar data
really really well so on so the goal is
that when you you run your code in the
simulator and it works it should work
well on our actual vehicle we also take
sensor data right now primarily camera
data but we're looking at ways to take
radar and lidar data and use them for
different projects so there are projects
in the computer vision module of the
course where you do Lane finding and
vehicle detection using camera images or
videos taken from from autonomous
vehicle cameras our autonomous vehicle
cameras so it's possible for us to send
you sensor data basically and that's how
you work with them what are the most
commonly used parts of math in the
course statistics calculus statistics is
probably the most common we'll use
Bayesian statistics just kind of shows
up everywhere in autonomous vehicles I
mean things like common filters and and
other types of filtering mechanisms and
algorithms when you're actually linear
algebra they even be more commonly used
statistics because you're doing a lot of
kind of systems of equations type
solving there's also a little bit of
calculus but it doesn't it's not as
prevalent basically if you're familiar
with derivatives and integrals of
polynomials back from high school or
college calculus then then you should be
in pretty good shape yeah you want to be
familiar with the notation and how to
implement it in code but not actually
we're not gonna make you solve an
integral or anything like that right you
should be familiar with I kind of
multiply matrices which is not difficult
if you've never done it and you take a
quick refresher we linked to a few on
our course home page you can pick that
up pretty quickly a lot of these
companies are requiring candidates to
have three to five years experience so
they actually interested in fresh
college graduates I would go yes but I
would say if you're kind of new brand
new to the area you have a little bit
more luck at a big company when you're
looking at these startups if maybe like
5 10 20 employees they're moving really
fast and they really need somebody who
can come in and just hit the ground
running and kind of provide stuff and so
you have a lot better chance I would say
getting a job at one of these bigger
companies where they have you know
hundreds of thousands of people and they
can kind of foster teaching you and
guiding you and helping you grow your
skills what are the obstacles to get to
level five well we should maybe first
define what what level five is you want
to take a crack at that sure so you've
kind of got a level one two and three
which are kind of like semi-autonomous
and these are SAE standards by the way
but their levels of you know fully
autonomy so that you've got like level
one is no like autonomy level two is
some drivers assistance level three is
more drivers assistance level four is
driving self driving in most conditions
and level five is completely on its own
self driving no human intervention this
is where you could take the steering
wheel out of the car and everything's
fine
there's technological restrictions to
that and then there's also like policy
restrictions to that and so
technological side is I I mean there's
just the world's unknown the roadways
are unknown people do sporadic things so
there's just a lot of unknown things
that computers have to be able to
understand and we're not quite there yet
and then the policy side is just you
know can we get a cup
to release the car without a steering
wheel in it and call it good and so
there's a lot of challenges around that
if it takes me three and a half years to
finish well there's still be jobs you're
getting your master's in CS this area I
mean it's always hard to predict the
future but this area doesn't seem to be
going anywhere anytime soon there is a
huge amount of investment from many many
companies in this sector in this sector
and all you're gonna see I think is
growth and more jobs and more you know
more entry-level jobs too or you know as
you finish up your master's definitely
you know ready to jump into that kind of
stuff yeah I mean we should highlight
hopefully it does not take you three and
a half years to finish the nanodegree
program yeah in fact I don't know that
we would let you take three and a half
years to finish the nanodegree program
in general you have to finish each term
in about three and a half months
complete the various projects that
usually four or five projects required
for the term you can take time off
between terms as long as you want so
that I guess would be the way you you
stretch it out for three and a half
years but but we certainly don't want it
want for you to have to take that long
to finish for the first term have any
machine-learning centric projects the
first term is pretty heavily dependent
on machine learning and deep learning
specifically so you build deep neural
networks to classify traffic signs and
the behavioral cloning project I
mentioned we're essentially you're
driving and recording data steering
wheel and throttle commands from from
you're driving around the simulator and
then you train a deep neural network to
mimic your own driving behavior and then
we use more standard computer vision
techniques to do things like lane
finding and vehicle tracking and even
there you can use machine learning
things like support vector machines to
classify whether different bounding
boxes have captured a vehicle or not and
you can use machine learning to tune
your hyper parameters for for Lane
detection so there's a lot of machine
learning in term one why don't we have a
point cloud processing project that's
it's a good question and the answer
basically is that the most important
thing that employers want based on our
conversations with employers
is facility with Coleman filters at
least they want for sensor fusion
engineers so point clouds are what you
get from from using a lidar to collect
data about the world basically just all
these little laser pingbacks in in a
point cloud if you've never seen one you
should type it into google image search
like lidar point cloud it's pretty neat
and so what we did for the for the
sensor fusion module is we took those
lighter point clouds and found where the
vehicles were in them and just returned
back a single point for the vehicle and
then have you do build common filters to
track those those points and vehicles
over time now of course the part we did
of taking the point cloud and figuring
out where in the point cloud the the
vehicles actually are and where the
centroid of that bounding box is isn't
is itself a very hard problem it's
possible we might build an advanced
sensor fusion elective module that would
incorporate working with with point
clouds and I would say it even seems
likely but nothing's for sure and and
that would be a really really neat
project but the first thing you really
have to master is using calm and filters
to contract those vehicle locations over
time because Coleman filters come into
play in a lot of different places for
self-driving cars is it difficult for a
bachelors in computer engineering to get
a job in self-driving cars I think
that's actually the perfect like kind of
background yeah I mean an interesting
thing is happening with self-driving
cars I'm that I even saw myself at Ford
which is that self-driving cars used to
exist in the research departments of
these big companies or in research
groups at universities and so it did
tend to be something that you needed a
PhD or at least a masters to work on and
self-driving cars are now just really
getting picked up fast by industry and
they're moving from the research
divisions into production division so
companies are are actually starting to
build these vehicles and one of the
things that you see at big automotive
companies is when something moves on to
a production track it becomes like a
freight train there's just nothing that
can stop it and when they're issues they
just kind of throw more engineers at it
and so the types of engineers that
you're seeing working on these projects
have gone from being kind of PhD
academic style researchers to really
like
industry software engineers people can
write code and get things done and so
having a PhD is still a huge asset you
know if you're particularly if you're
looking at working on the research end
of this but there's a lot of production
work going on now to actually get these
cars to work on the road for the final
project of people are gonna be able to
come to the office to see their code run
themselves yeah I think so so we were
just giving the first cohort of students
into the final project now and we just a
few weeks ago kind of got everything
finalized with our test track here in
Palo Alto and got that set up and so
we're working out how we're gonna have
students come to a lot to watch their
code run you you do not have to come to
Palo Alto to to watch your code run but
if you're interested you happen to be in
the area or you want to come to the area
um it's an opportunity we would like to
provide to you and so we're working out
the logistics of that yeah this is a
great comment I'm currently in the stuff
shopping cart program and David I just
want to say you do a great job of the
lessons and but a few of your engineers
look like they're being held held
hostage by Udacity little do you know
David has like a little room of
Engineers that he keeps and you can pull
out when he needs oh oh well we'll work
out some of that feedback but yes David
does do a great job in the class how are
mentoring in careers how do mentoring a
careers help
so our careers team is here to like
review your LinkedIn your resume github
I think I'll you're kind of professional
tools that when you go to an employer
that they might want to see our careers
team is here to help you with any of
that mentoring we switched from like
one-on-one kind of or I guess
one-to-many individual model or
mentoring model to a live help so now
there's a box that pops up and you can
type in and you can ask your question
and I think that's in the later cords
I'm still I think it's over turn three
right okay so we're looking at that
we're kind of seeing if that's gonna
help more but we're we have these two
models one where you have a mentor that
you can ask you a question to and they
get back to you in about 24 hours or so
and then the live help were it's you
have a box that pops up you can type
your question and then a mentor not
maybe your mentor but a mentor comes
back and gets to you within usually a
few minutes yeah I mean one of the
interesting things about self
in cars when we built it was started
building it we knew it was going to be a
pretty challenging program and that it
would be a really important program for
Udacity just in terms of visibility for
the company and so we started running a
lot of experiments and putting a lot of
resources in to see how can we help
students be most successful and one of
the experiments was mentorship giving
each student a mentor and we really see
like kind of binary feedback on that
there are some students who say they
just you know aren't really interested
in having a mentor it's not particularly
helpful and there are other students who
say that the mentor really like makes
the difference between them being able
to succeed in the program or not and so
one of the things we're trying to do is
really focus in on what makes those
mentor-student relationship successful
and then try and provide other tools for
folks who maybe just aren't interested
in that do you deploy every student's
code on Udacity car every student that
will join a team so we at the end you're
you join a team and your team will
deploy it so it's not every individual
it's just every team so every student
will can contribute to that code going
on to the car sounds like oh they yeah
deploying on the car is at the end of
the program yes and the terms are so
there are three terms in each term is
$800 is their age discrimination in this
field you're 43 and you're a web web
developer I hope that's not that's
illegal so hopefully there's not and we
we want everybody to join from hi so
when we have had everybody joined from
high school age - I don't know what our
highest or your oldest person is that is
joined but I don't if you can do this I
think these people compare but I care
about the jobs more like they want or
the skills they want you to they want
you to be able to do the job if you can
do the job yeah I mean it really is one
of those situations where there's such a
huge demand for people who can do the
work that that there's not a lot of room
to to be discriminatory yeah how does
the team project work with everybody
working remotely let's say nobody's in
your area a great question very it seems
kind of hard right but I so I actually
was part of this dude a self-driving car
race team that we did back in like April
and I was a student at that time and we
had 17 people from five different
countries and that's a really big
challenge when we could basically got
dumped in a slack Channel I had to
figure it out and within six weeks we
deployed code onto an actual car and
really only had the car for four days
two days before the event and we were
able to successfully deployed code on
there so I mean what's with the Internet
these days there's so many tools did you
allow collaboration and working together
and just yeah communication that it
you'll be able to make it happen and
we're also enabling the tools on our
side to make that easier for you so as
you get to term three we're running our
first students through that right now
we're gathering feedback seeing you know
what we did right what we did wrong and
then how we can make the process better
for every student as we go forward what
type of math is used I think we went
over that a little bit is there
necessary necessity into enrolling your
machine learning course and then
autonomous driving there's not you can
we're going to teach you the machine
learning pieces that you need to know
and so you know if you want to take the
machine learning one absolutely take it
but if you just want to take it to get
two autonomous vehicles then come take
our self-driving car course coming from
the deep learning foundations program
that is a deep learning part of
self-driving car does it do everything
from scratch again and what are the new
parts of the deep learning from
self-driving cars so we touch on some of
this stuff but we don't redo everything
that's in there and we do a lot more
outside of deep learning but and we do
more advanced pieces of deep learning
that the deep learning foundations
course doesn't get into yeah so one of
our team members actually was kind of
helped us build out the deep learning
component of the self-driving car nano
degree program and then bounced over to
our you dassey's deep learning nano
degree foundations program and so he has
kind of some good insight into both
programs and the way he likes to put it
is that the deep learning nano degree
foundations program is broader it covers
more things there are things that that
that program covers like natural
language processing using deep neural
networks and generative adversarial
networks that are fairly advanced topics
that we don't cover in self-driving car
because they're a little bit
relevant to getting a self-driving car
to run and we tend to focus a little
more just on the things that are
directly relevant to self-driving cars
like convolutional neural networks
transfer learning behavioral cloning
semantic segmentation and often the
projects that we have are more difficult
and like a little more kind of narrowly
focused on what you need for
self-driving cars so it's kind of a
weird deeper and maybe the deep warning
nanodegree foundations program is
broader what do you mean by a team
project for the final one do you mean
only one cope will run on the car
yes so you're working a team of about
four or five people and you work
together to get one you know concise
piece of code and you'll put will put
that on the car and we'll run that code
what if I can figure out how to code and
can work my way through the course but
I'm not a software engineer what are my
chances of getting a job I mean if you
get accepted of course and you get
through the course your chances are just
like anybody else if you can prove your
abilities I mean that's what employers
care about in this field they're care
about you being able to do the job and
solve the problems that need solve they
care a little bit less or a lot less
about your actual formal background
especially and it's very high in demand
so if you have these skills people
you're in demand with what respect do
you collaborate with sae international I
don't think we do anything with sae
international we don't have a direct
collaboration with them we like everyone
else in the industry relies a lot on
their level guidelines that you were
just talking about levels of autonomy
but we don't work directly with SAE are
we getting lied ours I wish we were like
Oprah and we could give lighters for
everybody by the lidar yeah
unfortunately not typical work or effort
needed for the course like we said
before 10 to 20 hours with you know
David said there's about a 17 about 17
hours is about average from what we're
seeing any on-site classes projects
meetups not what we do we support some
meetups we both doden David and I both
supported some different meetups we
don't have anything formally I guess
planned all the time
but if there's a meet-up in your area
that we're coming to your area we
definitely try to support that and we
are looking at other ideas that we can
do with you know in-person projects or
in-person classes or just defend the
ideas like that so that's something
we're still investigating them yeah we
like to do kind of in-person events when
they make sense and it's a little
opportunistic to suppose kind of
regularly scheduled so for example next
month in September I'm going to
Frankfurt Germany for the huge Auto Show
in Frankfurt and we'll be having a big
meet up with students in in Germany
while I'm there we've done similar
things in Denver and in Tokyo and
Washington DC Anthony's done in Boston I
think and we have a number of events
we've had a number of events here at our
Mountain View headquarters in California
yeah I might have lost quest show I
think I found where we were but so if
can somebody with no knowledge of any
sort and programming learned from
scratch with no degree so yes you can
this isn't the program probably for you
if you've never programmed before you
would you would hate yours you would
hate yourself you'd hate us for letting
you in and you wouldn't be happy but we
do have programs where like you can go
and you can learn about how to program
intro to programming is a great one and
then we just launched our data
foundations course so you could go there
and learn about kind of data analysis
and different pieces like that so we are
we are building this pipeline to take
you if you've never programmed before to
introduce you to that and then bring you
up to get you ready for self-driving
cars so but if you've never programmed
before I probably wouldn't recommend
this you just you would hate us you I've
seen a bunch of nasty comments in here
about you know me and David so we don't
want that could be a frustrating
experience yeah reposting question about
deadlines a little concerned about
keeping the pace week to week or weekly
deadlines so again there's weekly
flexibility in the deadlines but the
project or the end of the term is
definitely kind of the end of the term
so you want to have everything done
before that or all courses online work
at your own pace or their on-site
face-to-face opportunities if you're
ever in the area email one of us or post
in slack Tagus and slack or something
and David and I are usually really good
about trying to
with students and just have lunch with
you if you're in the area as far as
learning opportunities uh we don't
again that's stuff we're looking into we
haven't really done too many about that
yet
how many peers are in the program a lot
we've got thousands of people that have
joined the program and if you look at
our slack Channel I mean it's great
because there's you know a lot of
students out there that you can connect
with hopefully some in your area too
after this course will you be able to
retrofit code on on the current car what
is the total bill of material for
equipment so again this gets into we're
not really teaching how to build a
self-driving car like the physical
aspects of it but we're teaching you how
to code it so if you had a self-driving
car and you're working for a company
that has a self-driving car you would be
able to do the like algorithmic and the
AI and the problem-solving pieces of it
we're not teaching you how to like make
your car drive by wire that's much much
harder and there's a lot of risk
sometimes than that too it really is
kind of a different skill set to kind of
the work involved in actually like
getting the car to run involves a lot
more hardware which is great it's an
important excuse my skill set but a lot
of the the hiring that's being done
right now for autonomous vehicle
engineers or I should say the vast
majority of the hiring is for people who
have software engineering skills
certainly when I worked at Ford I worked
on vehicles occasionally but the vast
majority of my time was spent writing
software because that's what really
drives the car
are there any grads that have gone on to
found their own startups well we haven't
had any grads yet technically so but
there's a lot of opportunity for that
and you know hopefully you credit David
for teaching you how to you know program
your car and you know do your own
startup will there be any course staff
TAS that monitor and address questions
in the deforms yeah we have a lot of TAS
community managers Student Service leads
that kind of you know work in the forums
to make sure that your question is
answered can we translate the course to
Arabic we're looking into localization
in different areas I have I don't know
about Arabic yet well I don't know about
a lot of Mia we're still looking into
that
we definitely wants to be now that we
have all the course content finally out
there now we can go back and look at
what we want to translate and what we're
able to do Michael Lin says go Cubs go
Cubs what kind of industry slash ethical
standards are followed I don't know if
you mean for our course or for
self-driving cars in general our course
nothing really we're just you know we're
teaching you and there is some you know
I think with the electro fit piece
there's a ice iso standard that's
followed yeah so in the functional
safety module which is one of the
elective modules you can choose in the
eighth month of the program we cover
functional safety which is how to
program vehicles and algorithms so that
so that they have acceptable levels of
risk and in particular we follow a
standard by the international standards
organization called ISO 26262 more
generally where sometimes asked like do
we program ethics of self-driving cars
so like the famous trolley problem you
know if if you have to either go
straight and hit one person or turn
right and hit two people or maybe it's
reversed what do you do that's not
really what we cover in this course I'm
partly because that's more of an ethical
than an engineering problem and partly
because self-driving cars we believe
will just have such a positive impact
that sometimes to get lost in the weeds
about these these kind of hypothetical
academic questions about you know
trolley problems maybe kind of misses
the point that self-driving cars should
hopefully save a lot of lives because
humans are really bad drivers can I
complete the term or can I complete one
term in one month as well or is the core
structure than weak mouth scale so we
give you three months but I have seen
somebody completed as quick as three to
four weeks and so yeah if you get it
quicker then great you can move on to
term to faster or turn three faster
is there any grace period for the entry
fee or a refund that a student should
decide to cancel the course we do have a
seven-day grace period so if you get in
and you realize it's you know definitely
not what you're expecting we do have
option is Baidu is releasing
self-driving car package for free is
there any point to reinvent the wheel
well yeah so you're I'm guessing you're
talking about their Apollo program which
is still very new and I think Dave and I
are both looking into what that is and
what you know where it could be used but
it isn't excited mean it's awesome
anybody who's doing something
open-source we love that because we just
want to see people educated to this area
so I we're not we're not exactly
reinventing the wheel we're not trying
to teach you a specific way of doing
this we're just teaching you the
concepts that go into this so even if
you're using like up the Apollo stuff
you'll now know why it's working maybe
cuz they may have tracked that from you
but now you know why it's working and
then you can make it better to which as
a standard referring to 1939 I think is
a trucking standard for canvas but those
are kind of canned standards how good
should my basics for math stats be for
the nanodegree program they should it's
good to know like through calculus who
have been through calculus and
understand like Dave is saying like
linear algebra how to multiply matrices
and everything let's see if I can get to
one more program how to learn it faster
and put more effort in put more effort
yeah spend more hours per week that's
the best way I can say to learn it
faster there's a whole bunch of
questions that unfortunately we're not
gonna have time to get to so it sounds
like we're gonna have to do this again
David because you know they definitely
feel aside thank you so much for sending
in so many great questions we hope all
of you who are eligible enroll in the
nanodegree we really want to see you in
class and the folks who are already
enrolled in asking questions thanks so
much for the great questions you can
send them also to us on on the students
lacked community I'm I think I'm just
David Udacity in the Udacity employee
slack I'm David silver and the students
like I'm just David I mean Anthony you
are a Navarro a Navarro yeah so you can
find us on slack and again if you're
ever in the area feel free to stop by we
can have lunch have a beer yeah we love
you students at the office understand oh
yeah thank you for joining us
so much bye-bye